[Music]
we have the
portuguese uh gambit right with knight
f6 here to hit the pawn on d5
yeah but do do they know it's the
portuguese gambit is really the question
is this preparation or is this just
a little bit of inspiration over the
board because um
it must be you know this must be i don't
mind it's
fine let's not overthink it tim
yeah if we go up middle we both trade
i lose a little bit based on development
but that's the opening that you chose so
it's no problem
uh i think you were right it looks like
prep it looks like he
set out to play the portuguese gambit to
attack felix's queen
yeah and it makes sense i think
certainly he is the underdog um so i i
do like the idea of trying to go for
something early again
i felt that in all the matches where the
players sort of the stronger players
um outshine their opponents was in the
middle game or the end game
when when it got deeper and deeper into
the game and they just they weren't able
to
come up with the concepts as easily so i
think the opening phase is the most
important phase
um for the weaker players with players
who are perceived to be the weaker
players in terms of the uh the match
match setup for rubios it's very tricky
too because the ideas here are not
obvious h5 and f5 don't seem very
logical
based if you're just if you're just
getting um getting used to uh getting
getting used to chess so it seems like
moves that are not not so
um so common in a sense at the same time
you've done all the basics you've
developed and you've gotten your king
out knight before however
is not a move that i would have played
now i'm a little bit concerned
if xqc castles the king here i think
he's actually quite a bit better
having said that knight takes c2 would
completely explode
the position because he'll also win the
d3 pawn so something like
this this and then bishop takes and then
xqc is not going to be able to castle
short
so then then i don't know man then i
don't know it's gonna get
it goes e4 whoa okay
so i think x x q c will probably take
the knight here as my guess because
he'll see that pawn takes his bad
because he's going to be worried about
these tactics on uh with the pawn next
to his queen and the fork ideas
so i think he probably will take the
knight here check
all right take
he's calculating i can take rock and
push
if i take
he's only looking at this deep one right
now if i take
take
i'll take queen takes
i don't think he's realizing he actually
can take that knight and then take back
on f3
this is very annoying this is very
annoying the thing at the moment please
stop i actually stopped dude
so let's analyze why specifically the
move d4 led to such a
massive drop-off it's because when pawn
takes f3 happen cicara i'm assuming
you can no longer take the knight
because g2 correct
but again he takes on f3 i mean so far
everything rubius has done has been very
very impressive xvc has to take with the
bishop i feel like xc is a little bit
nervous
actually it seems like he's nervous and
he's not really sure of himself in the
way that he needs to be
um because some of these moves like d4
are very very unusual
from him oh well hey cara this was
expected after yesterday
but we've just crossed a hundred
thousand viewer threshold we're at a
hundred and one thousand viewers so
shout out to each and every one of you
so much love thank you all for being
here
wow this is crazy what we're seeing so
far i mean
in terms of the audience it's amazing in
terms of the chess this is uh this is
off to a very very bad start for xqc
that being said the one good thing
however is that the pawn on a7 is under
attack
that's the one good thing for x you see
here yes
so i think i mean again i think the
problem for xqc is he's also down on
time that's actually the biggest issue
that he has here
is not not even not even um the specific
position but the fact that he's down a
minute on the clock
however i do know when i when i was um
when i was doing stuff with with rubius
when we did the collaboration he was
also very slow and when he got low on
time
he was also panicking a little bit so if
rubius is not able to keep this big time
advantage
um i could see i could see uh
potentially some nerves and get getting
worried
um also oh we've wondered [__] f5 oh
boy
oh wow oh
just chill out for a second not too long
because he only has a minute and five
seconds
get his rook to safety and pushes other
pawns right
i mean again this is a very hard
position i think for both players to
play at this point
um the good thing for xcc though i think
it's he should i mean bishop g5 is the
move that i think he might play here
actually but
i don't i i wonder i think he's going to
go bishop g5 just to guess
oh my gosh that's such a stressful move
man
just a guess just again oh that's
probably wrong but it's just it's just a
guess
yeah you haven't been wrong yet so but i
oh my gosh actually he's got 30 seconds
he's also got to just move yeah
just just go as far away as possible
don't even think about it rook a7 keep
the king cut off
oh my god how did you know
[Laughter]
i told you i didn't feel like this was
gonna happen
are you kidding me
not the best move but it's okay
dude you're a genius
oh i [__] up he's just gonna discover
does he have any discovery here no it
doesn't
i'm still good to go i could put that
bit away but i should just disengage
that rook d5 is a great move though
great move by rubius fantastic move
one minute don't stop music
sideways checkmates one
two three done so
come on you can swim over there if he
wants to write
he can go to the right if he wants to
he saw the one square
[Music]
check
this is so epic
there's no stylemates here at least
right there's well there is one queen e6
is the only style mate
icarus stop stop it stop it
he's done it yes wow
yes baby are we going to go to the game
you know what oh
wow oh
[Music]
see early game you don't do that it's a
big mistake that's
terrible see what i did there good job
good job you you have him on the ropes
you got him on the [__] ropes one
more one more to go
he got all that hair off he lost all the
brain juice good [__] job
good [__] joke let's go let's go okay
one more one more
i mean yes made no real mistakes pretty
much picture perfect so
i think we've been underestimating um
underestimating rubies i think it's
going to be interesting to see because
i'm
very concerned uh xqc's openings with
black he's playing the petra off again
he's played this many many times um with
some very
poor results so it's it it's quite scary
to see this opening occurring again
and yeah like i was saying what's amazed
me so far is how well all the players
have done like
in the previous two editions there were
always moments where you you felt like
certain players were really
mismatched and kind of very early on in
the game you felt like it was just like
okay well unfortunately for the players
weaker they're just
you know they're they're not as strong
they're going to lose and it seems like
in this event
every time every match has been really
close the openings have been very
balanced
um and it's just great to see really
really great to see so far
everything he said is exactly how you're
supposed to approach a thought process
in chess
he played his idea saw what his opponent
could do
worked it out and said it's good he
evaluated it and look it's happening
d5 there it is he predicted it i also
thought i just looked up at this
he was trying to impersonate me or
something so i'm just looking at the sky
and start pointing every which way so
i did just notice him do that i'm not
sure i'm not sure what exactly was going
on but i did i did see that
well he inspires you and you inspire him
right back it's a
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful
relationship he's got to go to the
middle right
he's gotta the danger though is we saw
him arrowing towards a5 and c4
on the very edge of the board so that's
the one danger here
um if he puts a knight in the center i
think he's doing well if he goes the
other way i
i'm quite concerned um wow he does it
he does it yeah it's it's very hard to
under to figure out the attacking ideas
um
x2cc is using a lot of timing oh no oh
no oh no terrible move oh no
and you know it's actually a terrible oh
but you know what i realized i think
pawn takes pawn was a better move not
objectively but i think for
attacking ideas it was a better move
than this because now after xcc moves
his queen
um it's at least his king is safe still
fine it's fine we lost it it's fine did
it earlier we'll do it again
ow did you hear that hey kara
he just said we were minus three we'll
do it again just like you you guys are
completely in sync today like
but he's analyzing it now
[__] it's okay
i overthought it that's what happened
i think that's one of the best moves
good defense that's a great move
wow yeah let's pull that up
if if xqc doesn't realize that knight
takes d6 as a threat it could be all
over
okay and he's taken now we gotta get
queen takes
yeah rubies will take with the queen for
sure i don't think there's any question
about that
i don't really see how xcc is going to
survive this though because i feel like
now it's shifted the other way where
basically white is the one who has the
easy moves
like you can move the rook down the pawn
on d6 is also very weak
um and xcc doesn't really have any kind
of attack uh towards the white king so i
i i don't really know how he's going to
pull this one out i think most likely
rube is going to win this game
is really hurting actually he finds
queen b2 very nice move
yeah he finds queen b2 linking up the
queen in the rook and it's
is it even how is it even m11 is it like
queen takes b1
i think the computer is just crazy or no
because you can go king d7 somehow
and then survive right you sack the rook
and then yeah he's got to play queen
but what a comeback huge
yeah i think rubius has been putting in
a lot of work offshore as well as the
sense i get because he's playing this
very very well i mean once once he uh
once he
once he's got that extra bishop again
just very very good
and now no mouse slip by ruby it's just
queen b8 instead of queen b7
and um and that's game over and i expect
him to find it
yeah i i think he's just taking his time
because he has it i think last game he
blundered the bishop
right exactly yeah
he's maybe we can check in on his stream
to see the celebration right before
or as it happens
i don't know if we're gonna be able to
do that but he is drawing an arrow to b7
he's actually not even
oh no oh no
very tense he hasn't drawn it to b8
oh my gosh he got all the way there
in fact he should remove the arrow so he
sees that he can go the full length it
might just be like true
that's true he might be hindering his
own vision here oh my gosh
oh my gosh he might have this is crazy
he stopped to be
oh he's going the other way
oh no he missed it
all right let's pull this back up and
that is actually why
arrows help but you got to be able to
remove them also left click on any empty
square that you can't move to or
oh man wow and now the xcc finds bishop
to g7 it's game on again bishop g7 and
he finds it and now it's
now it's uh it's game on again this is
unbelievable
he has no check positions here with his
screen whoa
i haven't heard him say
that is unbelievable actually by the way
you know it's funny lovey it still says
mate in 14.
not so much how i don't know it says
mate and 14 for white i i really don't
know either but it's pretty funny
you can't do that yes it needs to go
upwards i mean mind you it's that's not
going to happen because
it's game on where can he go i see
here that's insane
oh my gosh wait what
queen takes excuse you can't believe it
and you know it's still not over
yeah it's still not over but i mean i
think again it's
oh i see it wow good move i
take he checks
what what
[Music]
boss man just take the bishop doesn't
matter
it's like the damn bishop
[Laughter]
she checks i block he takes i take
i need to get rid of that crossfire
though asap
all right he's playing really well
king d6 and there it is it's gone
now let's see if rubios can play rook a7
and get winning chances again or not
winning chance but try to create some
some sort of idea to keep it complicated
[Music]
yeah next uc is converting it seamlessly
and he's he's he's getting amped up fine
he can still go to the right and we can
discover him
think about it
lynn
very nice wow
wow amazing
dad let's go barbie
i i didn't want to expect anything you
know uh coming out of your opponents i
just
i just played my game right so my plan
was just to play my game and not like
think about his rating or his projected
skill whatever and um
all of his openers i know how to
transition from from early game to mid
game
and i all my pieces were all scattered
and stuck in in blocks
and it opened up tons of good moves from
and i was lost i i didn't know what to
do how to move
and um you know i i couldn't breathe the
whole time
i was only playing his game and i was
never playing my game
and uh that stressed me out i think i
only won because
um he made mistakes uh later on in his
game
right because i never got to play mine
so i'm happy about the wins
i'm like i'm happy but um i think i
could have done so much better
so at the beginning it was uh i
i felt like i was ahead of him like i
had
many more pieces than him uh at the
beginning or at the mid match
but at the late game i always grew up
because i get
like confident overconfident and then i
start making mistakes
and so yeah i think that happened in
both of the matches like
in the beginning uh i was like a little
bit ahead but then at the end it was
like boom
so but it was really fun like like we
were saying uh after
before we did like many mistakes both of
us like i did a pepeka move he did a
pepeka move
and then he did a genius move and then i
do a normal move a good mood
so yeah it was like i felt
like it was like he was saying like real
chess so i enjoyed it really much
i started playing like uh three months
ago or something like that like
and it was also not because of queen's
gambit but it was uh
because the the previous spock times
where xqc
failed in six moves after that i began
watching more more test streams and it
was thanks to xqc and
hikaru so yeah sweet
i don't remember that six moves i'm not
sure i like the
like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
yeah with moisty critical it was amazing
oh yeah um
[Music]
you